a Libyan guard on patrol near the border
with Tunisia he's discovered a stranded
man with a four-month-old baby
right here right here see this baby can
you imagine how difficult it is for a
baby this young to survive under the hot
sun we need to document this and
hopefully International Organization
will do so too for God's sake this is so
wrong
temperatures here reach 50 degrees
Celsius and the family has no water or
food
hundreds of migrants have been rounded
up by Tunisian security forces in the
city of sfax in recent weeks
some have been left here in the middle
of the desert they say with no access to
health care or any type of humanitarian
support
others are stranded in a narrow buffer
zone between Tunisia and Libya
conditions are dire the migrants say
they're desperate and are appealing to
the United Nations for help
we are begging on the new end to please
come to our head we are suffering here
brutally look at our skin and be
infected we defend infection no
treatment no food they have been Matrix
maliciously which is very wrong my
treating our women wrapping our women
destroying our phone
Tunisia and the European Union recently
announced a deal aimed at stopping
migrant boats and shutting down people
smuggling operations
Tunisian president Kaya Saeed has said
migrants arriving there receive Humane
treatment
the human rights watches accused the
Tunisian government of collective
expulsion of black migrants
many say they've been trapped here for
more than two weeks and they're
frustrated more isn't being done to help
them Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera